New Orleans is a city whose exuberance
is difficult to contain
in late February as people rub shoulders
in the annual Mardi Gras parades few
were aware COBIT 19 was silently present
and spreading now the streets are empty
and the hospitals are filled but despite
appearances the city's Big Easy Spirit
simmer strong the New Orleans community
will stick together no matter what the
situation is tasty treat restaurant
still serves up classic Creole dishes
despite the loss of its regular
customers it has a new customer a
charity called
feed the front line NOLA which emerged
from the epidemic the group collects
online donations buys food from 40 local
restaurants and gifts the meals to
tak'st workers at 16 New Orleans
Hospitals does not not worry about where
our next meals coming from the morale
boost is shocking the charity was
founded by a fraternal group called the
crew of red beans their goal to help New
Orleans get through co19 just as it
survived Hurricane Katrina 15 years ago
we already have experienced catastrophic
loss and rebuilding so I think it kind
of gives an extra oomph to the community
spirit but it's not just the restaurants
and hospital workers who benefit
the charity pays out-of-work musicians
to make the deliveries its steady income
coming in to my bank account and not
only that more importantly it's giving
me service work and it's given me
something to do with my day it's given
me a purpose and a very hopeless time
the effort has yielded more than 2,000
meals a day deliver to the frontlines
what other way when the wall is be able
to give pay besides giving out the most
things that we're known for which is the
music and our food more signs of New
Orleans as resilience in the face of
adversity
hi Joe Castro al Jazeera